As a final step to this class, we're going to go in and actually just add a small turntable
rotation to the vehicle just to give it a little bit of movement and see our lighting
in action as it kind of glances over all the various different surfaces.
So if I jump back to our scene, so I'm going to open up this 06 final, which should have
everything involved.
Now on the Audi A5, you may see a rotational component.
So if we just select that vehicle and in the route here has like a rotation movement, go
ahead and select it, delete it, and we'll start from there.
So just to recap in our scene what we have happening, so we've got our neutralized baseline.
We've got our artistic effects added over the top.
Now if you want to see what's been modified, great and easy way to do this is select this
little settings cog.
I apologize, this is off screen, but there should be a show only modified properties
and this will show you everything that's been changed over the base.
So you can see how we achieve this visual look by simply using this artistic effect.
So again, if I turn it off, there's our neutral, turn it on, you see now we have these effects.
All right, so with the Audi A5 DS selected, I'm actually going to go to this component
here and what I'm going to do is click the little add button and I'm going to search
for rotation.
So I'm going to do add, add rotation movement, it's fine like that.
And I'm going to go ahead and turn off my show only modified properties and underneath
the rotation movement, simply put, all I got to do is go down to rotation movement and
instead of 180, which is going to be very fast, let's change this to something like
15.
All right, now what I can do is go up to my settings.
Now in this case, I'm going to use simulate.
You could use selected viewport, but I'm going to use simulate.
And as soon as we do that, you see our vehicle now starts to rotate.
And there we have it.
That's going to conclude what we've built in this introduction to automotive visualization.
With our lighting, again, just to recap real quick what we've covered.
We've established our scene, we've put in all of our different components, all of our
different calibration tools.
We've then gone in, we've used a isolation approach to our lighting to add our lights,
add our artistic effects or whatever we want to with those particular lights, hide them
at all in the rest, balance, and then finally go in and add a post-processing volume to
be able to add back some of those visual effects that we're looking for.
And then lastly, by simply just adding a little bit of raz and dazzle to this, by adding a
rotational movement to our actual Audi itself to be able to see the thing rotate in our
scene.
And that will conclude this course.